let's go next to
uh let's go to tai from connecticut tai
from connecticut you're on the air
hey how's it going good yeah vienna
sounds pretty nice right now
yeah with that other place
i my question is a two-parter okay and
it's a little more abstract
than i think the other questions been a
little more direct a little more kind of
in the weeds do you think that
donald trump is an effective
political communicator
well see here's what's very interesting
trump's statements
trump's delivery is one of the most
incoherent i've ever heard from a
president
in the sense that he will you know
make up words say things that don't make
sense say one thing and then say the
opposite
never answer a question lie like
analyzing it objectively you can barely
put together a sentence
if you're if you're like logical and
rational but at the same time
which is what i'm going to do at the
same time his way his method of
communication has been hugely effective
to the people that are even likely to
consider voting for him right so right
his method won't work for somebody who
sees trump and says this is a grotesque
ignorant buffoon
but for folks who are open to the idea
of being told the reason
you don't make more money is because of
china and i will fix it or mexico and i
will fix it
it it actually is effective so so
the answer it's not a there's not a
clear-cut answer it depends on who
you're trying to appeal to
right so the second part is
and you can you can rearrange the
question
how you want but i kind of want to try
to
do a broader subject which is do you
think sort of the democratic
establishment
uh the you know i don't know the dnc
nancy pelosi uh chuck schumer
barack obama joe biden hillary clinton
do you think that they
are effective political communicators
and i'm gonna actually add this too
yeah uh and you can you can answer it
however you want but i i
maybe you can even touch back on the
trump thing i think when i think of the
question like effective political
communicator i think of like
getting what they want done whether
whatever what they want is if i or you
might disagree with it
do you think that they are effective
political communicators in that way and
i'm just gonna the reason why i'm asking
the question is i don't think they are
and i suspect that you might and i
i want to hear kind of like your
explanation why you do because honestly
of the people
of the people you listed the only one
that i think is really an effective
political communicator is barack obama
yeah right i mean it's like nancy pelosi
and chuck schumer you know they're
they're in the positions they're in not
because of
being gifted speakers they're in the
positions they're in because of being
gifted schmoozers and fundraisers
and insiders um as far as hillary
clinton and joe biden
you know joe biden is not what he was at
one point i think
in the late uh in the early 2000s
and while he was vice president i think
joe biden was quite an effective
political communicator although he
wasn't always in positions of
of that speech making as big of a
difference but of the people you listed
barack obama is the one that really you
know bill clinton in his heyday was a
very effective political communicator
and as you're saying this is aside from
policy
but no the people you listed mostly are
not great communicators
what then you have to consider as a
whole sort of the democratic
establishment and look
is the republican establishment good
political communicators i'm not
sure maybe to their demographic yes
exactly
i guess just to sort of uh round up the
question
the democratic establishment as a whole
if they want to
you know and this is this is kind of
where i get frustrated presumably
their agenda is not the republicans
agenda right
so i mean you know if
if you have an agenda that's not the
republicans agenda are you effective
at getting people to be motivated to
politically
whether it be vote for you or whatever
go you know vote in the senate whatever
you know are are you you know and this
is where i
kind of from the left get really
concerned and i think that your comments
have been
actually rather refreshing but yeah as
the establishment because i think this
is where they need to
you know i think they i think everyone
thinks this and is looking at this
honestly like you know
you know it's like a branding problem i
guess if you're yeah and listen that's
we've been you know check out my
interview from who knows how long ago
uh with george lakoff about this issue
like i've not i've not hesitated to uh
to point this out it's absolutely a
problem listen i've gotta run because
i've got a bunch of people to get to i
appreciate the call
we're taking just a very very quick
break if you're holding on to talk to me
don't hang up because i'll be going
right back to the phones momentarily
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even
fill the card number with one click and
the payment is
taken out of your checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a 10 a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com pacman